we're asked to find the value of x in
the isosceles triangle shown below so
that is the base of this triangle so
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
well the key realization to solve this
is to realize that this altitude that
they dropped this is going to form a
right angle here and a right angle here
and notice both of these triangles
because this whole thing is an isosceles
triangle we are going to have two angles
that are the same this angle is the same
as that angle these because it's an
isosceles triangle this 90 degrees is
the same as that 90 degrees and so the
third angle needs to be the same so that
is going to be the same as that right
over there
and since you have two angles that are
the same and you have a side between
them that is the same this side this
altitude of length 12 is on both
triangles we know that both of these
triangles are congruent so they're both
going to have 13 they're gonna have one
side that's 13 one side that is 12 and
so this and this side are going to be
the same so this is going to be x over 2
and this is going to be x over 2 and so
now we can use that information and the
fact and the Pythagorean theorem to
solve for X let's use the Pythagorean
theorem on this right triangle on the
right hand side we can say that x over 2
squared that's the base right over here
this side right over here we could write
that x over 2 squared plus the other
side plus 12 squared is going to be
equal to our hypotenuse squared is going
to be equal to 13 squared this is just
the Pythagorean theorem now and so we
can simplify this is going to be X into
that same color this is going to be x
squared over 4 that's just x squared
over 2 squared plus 144 144 is equal to
13 squared is 169 now I can subtract 144
from both sides I'm going to try to
solve for X that's the whole goal here
so subtracting 144 from both sides and
what do we get on the left-hand side we
have x squared over 4 is equal to 169
minus 144 let's see 69 minus 44 is 25 so
this is going to be equal to 25 we can
multiply both sides by 4 to isolate the
x squared and so we get x squared is
equal to 25 times 4 is equal to 100 now
if you're just looking this purely
mathematically you say oh X could be
positive or negative
10 but since we're dealing with
distances we know that we want the
positive value of it so X is equal to
the principal root of 100 which is equal
to positive 10 so there you have it we
have solved for X this distance right
here the whole thing the whole thing is
going to be equal to 10 half of that is
going to be 5 so if we just look at this
length right over here I'm doing that in
the same color let me see so this length
right over here that's going to be 5 and
indeed 5 squared plus 12 squared that's
25 plus 144 is 169 13 squared so the key
realization here is isosceles triangle
the altitude splits it into two
congruent right triangles and so it also
splits this base into two so this is x
over 2 and this is x over 2 and we use
that information and the Pythagorean
theorem to solve for x